choosing someone to take over a role
from another actor is never easy
especially when the original actor drew
praise for their take on a character but
recasting is often an unavoidable factor
filmmaker especially for sequels and
remakes whether it's creative
disagreements financial setbacks or
simple timing issues at hand actors
often become unavailable to resume their
roles and must be replaced
sometimes the newcomer can blend right
in to the blockbuster scene unnoticed
but in the case of these casting
switcheroos the change was just too
drastic for audiences to endure
clarice starling when director Ridley
Scott signed on to direct the Silence of
the Lambs sequel he did so without his
clarice starling in place Anthony
Hopkins had already negotiated a return
to the role of Hannibal Lecter but Jodie
Foster didn't share his enthusiasm for
the second chapter in the serial killer
story despite winning an Oscar for the
role in the first film she later told
Total Film the official reason I didn't
do Hannibal is I was doing another movie
for a plum so I get to say and a nice
dignified way that I wasn't available
when that movie was being shot but
Clarice meant so much to lambs director
Jonathan Demi and I there was no way
that either of us could really trample
on her now that's really interesting
Mary's
I'm really pressed for time several
big-name actresses were considered to
take her place and the part ultimately
went to Julianne Moore while both Scott
and Hopkins were happy with the choice
audiences weren't as convinced Moore was
inevitably compared to foster and
couldn't measure up to her predecessors
screen savvy nor rekindled the creepy
connection Clarice had shared with
Hopkins in the first film Jodie Foster
offered her own diplomatic but shady
take on the film saying simply I saw
Hannibal I won't comment Evelyn
O'Connell the mummy was a surprise smash
for Universal hosting global receipts of
415 million dollars and landing on the
top 10 highest-grossing films in 1999 it
launched Brendan Fraser's career as a
Hollywood action hero and introduced the
world to a stunning new leading lady in
Reichle vice the pair made a compelling
on-screen couple and reprised their
roles in The Mummy Returns which managed
to bring in a nice haul from the box
office as well but by the time the third
film came around Vice was suffering from
some serious mummy fatigue and stepped
aside vice was rumored to call the
script for The Mummy 3 crap so the
studio turned to Maria Bello to fill in
for the role unfortunately for Bella her
turn in the role was criticized for
lacking the charm of the original
and the film failed to recoup its
production cost in the domestic
box-office
Waterboro free the genie the nineties
marked a moment of resurgence for
Disney's animated film collection with
films like Beauty and the Beast and The
Lion King offering a new generation of
children some cartoon movies to sing
along to one of Disney's most beloved
films of the era was Aladdin an
oscar-winning take on the Arabic folk
tale about the street thief who sheds
his rags and won the heart of a princess
Aladdin was packed full of great musical
numbers but the main reason it became
such a smash was the input of the late
Robin Williams as the genie
it's all part and parcel the whole genie
gate the actor confirmed that he
wouldn't be lending his voice to the
direct-to-video sequel the return of
Jafar after an alleged row with Disney
over its marketing tactics so the search
for a new genie began dan Castellaneta
the legendary voice of Homer Simpson was
ultimately chosen to voiced a big glue
gun but the Simpson star just couldn't
measure up to Williams frenetic
performance the quality of the animation
didn't help matters but Castellaneta
lacked the unpredictability that
Williams brought to the genie
essentially doing a watered down
impression of his predecessor don't Jack
Ryan there are five films based on Tom
Clancy's Jack Ryan books but only one
actor has played the protagonist twice
eyebrows were raised when Alec Baldwin
was given the boot after he's
successfully debuted Ryan on-screen in
The Hunt for Red October
Baldwin later implied that the studio
had gone behind his back and entered
into negotiations with Ford to take the
role of Ryan well that was a guess but
it seemed logical
even so Ford's performance in Patriot
games and clear and present danger
became definitive for the character
eight years later another actor stepped
in to bring a much younger version of
Jack Ryan to the big screen this time it
was Ben Affleck who stepped in for the
sum of all fears his performance in the
role was met with disdain however in the
Jack Ryan franchise never really
recovered after that despite an attempt
to reboot it with Chris Pine in the lead
role more than a decade later Sarah
Connor following in the footsteps of
Linda Hamilton as Sarah Connor in the
Terminator franchise was never going to
be easy for any actress Hamilton gave a
performance so layered in compelling
that even those talented performers have
struggled to do
character justice the first to give it a
shot was Lena Headey who was cast in the
role in the short-lived TV series
Terminator the Sarah Connor Chronicles
Fox canceled the show after two seasons
citing its high cost as a reason but
heddes gameofthrones colleague emilia
clark was willing to give it another go
on the silver screen for Terminator
Genisys the film was a box-office duck
and was heavily criticized for using the
old time-travel chestnut to rewrite the
beginning of the Terminator story to
suit the filmmakers purposes the main
problem wasn't the infuriatingly muddled
timeline though it was the casting as
much as TV lovers Mike dig Clarke's
portrayal of Daenerys Targaryen and Game
of Thrones the film crowd was decidedly
not wowed by her run as Sarah Connor
where her line deliveries packed a lot
less punch than the original Paz Van
Wilder
National Lampoon's Van Wilder isn't
going to be preserved in the Library of
Congress National Film registry anytime
soon yet for all of its failings fans of
a certain age remember this movie fondly
this was a time when frat humor was at
its peak and sitting down to watch a
comedy usually meant turning your brain
off for 90 minutes Van Wilder might not
have been the most cerebral comedy of
all time but Ryan Reynolds still
delivered as the fast-talking cool guy
who threw the best parties and was a
softy underneath all those crazy antics
after the Cowpens led sequel was
destroyed by critics the producers
decided their next move was a prequel
featuring a younger version of Van
Wilder so they brought in Mean Girls
Jonathan Bennett for Van Wilder freshman
year which was a terrible mistake I have
never seen such a sorry display in all
my life the actor couldn't come close to
the charisma of his predecessor and
produced a feature-length failed
impression effort as a result Willie
Mays Hayes major-league was a surprise
Grand Slam for Paramount Pictures and
produced two increasingly terrible
sequels and while Charlie Sheen's Wild
Thing came back for a second round at
the bound in major league - there is
another standout actor from the first
film who refused to run the basis of
this franchise again Wesley Snipes whose
charming swagger as the speedy bass
thief was a home run in the first movie
had no interest
returning to the dugout for the second
movie at the time he was well on his way
to becoming a Hollywood MVP in his own
right
thinks the movies like white men can't
jump and demolition man so he pretty
much priced himself out of the second
movie with the Cleveland Indians down a
man on their roster the filmmakers
turned a relative newcomer Omar Epps to
sub in as a pinch runner for the project
and fortunately Epps didn't have a
strong background in comedy and his
performance was the cinematic equivalent
of a foul ball read some of your reviews
man one guy said Willie Mays Hayes
couldn't play damn just a bit outside
halibuts Dumbledore the prisoner of
azkaban might still be a favorite among
some Harry Potter fans thanks to the
arrival of Sirius Black and that wild
whomping willow but the fact remains
that it's the lowest grossing movie in
the franchise and for many the subdued
enthusiasm seems to stem from the
unfortunate arrival of a new Hogwarts
headmaster in the film richard Harris's
take on Albus Dumbledore in the first
two movies had become definitive for
Potter fans so when the actor died after
a battle with Hodgkin's disease the
filmmakers had to turn to another actor
to step in to the beloved professors
cloak Michael Gambon seemed like a fine
choice to conjure up for the franchise
but his performance in his first run as
Dumbledore was stunted by the fact that
he'd never read the books rather than
resuming Harris's spellbinding ly calm
and wise demeanor Gambon delivered a
much more Stern and aggressive version
of the character for his first few
outings solute or gammon would later
summon up the same sort of chill pill
that saved the role from being ruined
for children across the globe but these
moments of mismatching between the
beloved book character and the screen
interpretation still cost the movies
many house points in the eyes of the
true Potter fanatics Catwoman Halle
Berry taking over Michelle Pfeiffer's
role in Catwoman is perhaps the most
infamous example of recasting going
terribly wrong
DC's leather clad heroine has appeared
in numerous Batman adaptations over the
years but Pfeiffer's psychotically sexy
performance in Tim Burton's Batman
Returns remains - cat's meow
so much yummy
the actress initially intended to
reprise the role in the solo spin-off
but after years of development blows her
patience reached its limit and she
decided to concentrate on other
commitments after a rigorous recruiting
process Berry was ultimately chosen to
climb into katsu and what a mess it all
was the film was a complete disaster
bombing hard at the box office while
cleaning up at the Razzies Barrie took
her worst actress bland and good humor
and even turned up to accept your award
in person Batman another error in
judgment from the Batman universe
occurred when Michael Keaton handed over
the keys for Wayne Manor to Val Kilmer
Keaton had portrayed the role in 1989's
Batman and its sequel Batman Returns but
he refused to reprise the role in a
third film after reading the screenplay
when pressed for details
Keaton later said that the script he was
shown sucked and that it was just awful
pointing the blame for his departure
squarely at the writers Val Kilmer
clearly didn't share Keaton's opinion
the tombstone star accepted the role and
went into the film knowing he'd have to
contend with a wide cast of wacky
villains as well as a new director Joel
Schumacher ultimately shouldered a lot
of the blame for the badness of Batman
Forever though his leading man didn't
escape criticism what am I
please you're as blind as a bat he was
quickly replaced with George Clooney and
Batman and Robin the good news for
Kilmer is that Clooney's turn as The
Dark Knight wasn't any more loved than
his own and soon everyone forgot about
Kilmer's turned in the Batmobile forget
it take off it's Val Kilmer thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel let's
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to
[Music]